Bonjour.
Connaissez-vous le site WikiHow ?
Nous essayons d'aider chaque personne sur la planète à apprendre comment tout faire , rejoignez-nous !
C'est un site regroupant des articles pour t'apprendre, à faire, à vivre finalement.
Comment réussir un examen, comment plaire à une fille à l'école,
comment être heureux tous les jours..
Et chaque article est accompagné d'une petite illustration censé le représenter.
Comme par exemple cette image qui représente
l'article "Comment jouer à action ou vérité?".
Est-ce-qu'avec seulement l'image vous auriez pu trouver le nom de l'article?
La réponse est peut-être.
C'est parti, on commence avec du boobs direct.
On a donc à chaque fois quatre propositions de titre d'article
et faut trouver laquelle est bonne.
"Comment trouver un mari quand les femmes sont plus nombreuses que les hommes dans ton pays?"
"Comment faire une Lap Dance pour ton copain ou mari?"
"Comment aider les gens paranoïaques?"
ou "Comment dire à une fille que tu l'aimes?"
Bah.. C'est le dernier.
Ou alors le premier en mode y a trop de femmes du coup personne pour lui toucher les seins.
Et moi je dirais la dernière.
*Bonne réponse*
Yeah !
Ok, suivant.
C'est un mec qui pense à un mec qui a peut-être euh..
plusieurs émotions.
*inspiration*
Est-ce qu'on crois en  cette description ?
"Comment danser en boîte de nuit?"
"Comment échanger avec une personne sarcastique?"
"Comment être un adolescent studieux ?"
Oh non vous m'avez grillé !
"Comment réagir au fondamentaliste?"
J'dirais "Comment gérer une personne sarcastique".
[correct]
BOOOOM !
2-0 !
2 pour moi, 0 pour vous.
Et vous allez rester à 0 puisque vous pouvez pas jouer.
Ok, play again, c'est trop facile.
Oh putain, juste une horloge avec plein d'aiguilles ?
"Comment gérer avec des parents très chrétiens?"
"Comment se sentir bien dans sa peau?"
"Comment faire des cauchemars?"
ou "Comment transformer une fille ?"
Une horloge avec genre en mode "Ah quelle heure est-il?"
"Ah je suis perdu", "Ah je suis pas bien dans ma peau" ?
Ah, j'ai eu faux !
Comment faire des cauchemars ?!
Et y a le lien vers le vrai article?
Mais qui suit un tuto pour faire des cauchemars ?
Alors, il faut dormir le visage vers l'oreiller,
il faut essayer de manger certains trucs avant de dormir
Oh bah je peux te dire qu'avec ce piment mon pote c'est plutôt aux toilettes que tu vas passer la nuit!
Fais-toi peur avant d'aller dormir,
Prends de la vitamine B6 ?!
Attends mais c'est un délire mec !
Ok y a une bouche fermée , c'est  validé, une bouche ouverte, c'est pas validé.
"Comment faire du alto-saxophone?"
C'est ça, j'suis sûr, mec.
Voilà fin du game !
Je sais pas d'où je sors cette connaissance mon gars,
j'crois que c'est dans le cauchemar que j'ai provoqué cette nuit.
Excellent ce petit running gag, hein ?
J'sais plus où j'a vu ça mais faut pas faire ça ?
faut faire :
*démonstration magnifique*
Prof de musique à mi-temps, je sais ça se voit.
Ok c'est une fille avec un appareil photo ou une longue vue, je sais pas
"Comment acheter des armes à feu en Californie ?"
What the fuck !?
"Comment choisir une université rigoureuse pour ta première année ?"
"Comment être moins collant?"
"Comment reconnaître les signes d'intoxication?"
J'pense c'est être moins collant.
En mode sur la photo elle observe au loin comme ça
J'étai le seul à faire ça au collège ?
Oh ouiiii !
Déjà ça c'est une fiole de laboratoire donc ça doit être un truc en rapport.
"Comment faire en sorte qu'un mec que tu as saoulée t'aimes la prochaine fois que tu le vois?"
"Comment être taquin ?"
"Comment savoir quand tu auras tes premières règles?"
ou "Comment s'amuser sans tes amis ?"
Bon alors c'est peut être un sale mais c'est pas le délire euuh avec les cuillères à soupe de sang?
Genre euh.. Par rapport aux règles sur une semaine ça fait peut-être 5 cuillères à soupe de sang..
cinq cuillère à soupe de sang
je...
Voila on le prépare une potion pour que le mec qui ne l'aime plus l'aime a nouveau BIP
NON "Comment savoir quand tu auras tes premières règles?" P*tain
Ma théorie des cuillerations était pas mal
Ah la y'a du challenge
Une femme qui regarde d'un air étonnée sa collègue qui pense a un chat avec une moustache
"Comment savoir si ton copain te manque du respect?"
"Comment être intéressante?"
"Comment aimer" ou "Comment être un bon mari"
Comment être intéressante ? Bah ouii
Oh il est bien .Il y a deux aventuriers qui cherchent quelqu'un a priori
"Comment survivre dans le bois?"
"Comment savoir si ta copine veut faire l'amour?"
"Comment acheter des électroniques usagés?"
"Comment refuser un bisou?"
Bah je dirais qu'ils sont dans les bois et qu'ils s'appellaient a l'aide parce qu'ils sont dans la merde
Donc "Comment survivre dans les bois?"
J'suis un génie
ho p*tin un mec nous embrouille
notre notre coeur bat super vitte
"comment réagir si quelqu'un te traite de moche !"
"comment voir à travers les gens"
"comment se faire percer les tétons"
*rires*  what ?!
ça c'est un abonné ça, ça c'est un abonné qui apprécie l'tété !!
"comment garder son calme"
mais ils n'auraient pas fait un article aussi ciblé que :
"que faire si quelqu'un dit que tu es moche ?"
nan , je pense que c'est le dernier "comment se calmer"
ET BOOMMM !!!
"un mec qui allume sa clope à l'envers avec une allumette"
"comment reconnaître les signes d'intoxication"
"comment gagner un combat au poing"
"comment écrire un sketch"
ou "comment être unique"
bon le délire d'intoxication , c'est sûr.
ba oui, ho c'était facilelounet ça !
HO p**in
une fille que se fait éclabousser !
"comment comprendre l'ego des hommes"
ssssssssss
ça nous concerne beaucoup !
"comment faire une blague ou comment faire preuve de respect".
j'dirait que c'est la blague.
ouais
ba oouuuuui
*claquement de doigt*
ho pu*in ! un couple qui regarde un mec jouer au bowling
on n'a jamais vu ça !
personne ne regarde du bowling à la télé en couple !
"comment être jolie"
"comment montrer à votre mari que vous l'aimez"
"comment capturer la joie de vivre"
"ou comment faire face à la mort d'un ami"
je dirais soit comment montrer son amour envers son mari genre :
"regarder sa passion à la tété alors que t'aime pas forcément ça"
en l'occurrence le bowling.
soit la joie de vivre soit ça peut tout être là en fait
allez, on va dire ce que je vous ais dit..
ouiiii !!
hoo !
une fille qui sait sxexe s'exclame
"comment être sans émotion"
"comment faire des crasses à ton copain"
"comment ne pas être nerveux"
"ou comment faire en sorte.." *rires*
ou comment rentre quelqu'un que tu à rencontré sur msn amoureux de toi !
c'est soit ne pas ressentir d'émotion, soit ne pas être nerveux.
mais ne pas être nerveux on l'a vu tout à l'heure..
donc je dirais c'est ça.
sans émotion..
"comment elle gère salement avec son copain".
"réagir un truc banal avec une réaction exagérée".
"tu as mangé deux bananes à toi tout seul, t'est sûr que t'en à fait pas tombée une ?!"
ha ouais... non mais là les gars... la c'est level professionnel là !
ho putain elle est magnifique celle-la !
"comment perdre son visage?"
"comment s'amuser sans ses amis ?, comment savoir si ton copain est irrespectueux en vers toi ?"
"comment est attirante en rendez-vous ? Comment refuser un bisous ?".
juste une meuf qui *mmmmaa*...
a refusé un bisou en mode elle prend son visage elle l'envoie ailleurs.
loin du visage de l'autre...
je pense que le bisou hein ?
c'est comment s'amuser sans ses amis ?!
sa représente quoi cette putain d'illustration, mais elle est même pas dedans !
elle y est même pas !
ho la douille !!
"comment utiliser le français dans une conversation à propos des mammifères, allez c'est ça !"
hoooooooooooohohoho !!
et voilà, moi j'ai pas le temps !
bon par contre mec, j'aimerais bien ou ils ont casé cette illustration.., à en fait c'est un tuto
pour apprendre le nom d'animaux en français.
et l'image elle correspondait à l'instruction "collez chaque mot à la carte correspondante"..
c'est passionnant
mais je parle français couramment, je m'en bats les couilles !!!
ok, quelqu'un qui se baisse, "comment survivre à un hiver froid ?"
"comment savoir si tu va avoir tes premières règles ?, comment rendre un ami amoureux de toi, comment faire une danse emo ?"
haa, ça peut être la danse ça !
non, c'est débile !
je pense que c'est survivre à un hiver froid..
enfin un vieux truc, un vieux move qui fait que tu as moins froid, je sais pas...
hé ba c'est de la merde cette théorie
comment faire une danse "emo", putain non !
y a vraiment des mecs ils lisent ce tuto pour de vrai.
d'accord, un mec qui fait "non ça ira !".
comment refuser poliment un tract dans la rue ..
tu parie ? "comment péter silencieusement?".
bon on en est très loin...
"comment être le genre de geek que les filles adorent ? comment parler avec autorité ? comment arrêter de fixer le décolleté des filles ?".
bon vu c'est la dernière, on va faire toutes les options ensemble !
soit sur l'image il dit : "c'est pas moi qui ai pété" soit c'est l'image du geek un peu BG (beau gosse) qui dit : "non désolé je ne suis pas intéressé filles"
c'est peu probable quand même, parler avec autorité : j'ai même pas de théorie.
arrêter de fixer le décolleté, je pense que c'est :
[musique épique très inutile]
ha noooon !!
c'était comment arrêter de regarde les décolletées des filles :( ...
tiens, bah comment faire ? dites-nous !
étape 1 : regarder ailleurs, merci très bon site !!
[bip]
bon voilà c'est la fin de cette vidéo , n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu !
je m'en remets pas de cette étape 1, mec xD
he ba c'était bien sympa ce petit jeu ! on va pas se mentir, peu être une deuxième vidéo dessus voilà la revanche, on veut avoir le septante (70%) de bonnes réponses !
qui correspondent à un petit 14 sur 20 , 10% de 20 sa fait 2 x 7 =14 voilà !
merci d'avoir regardé comme d'habitude que vous vous portez bien et tous se passe bien dans votre vie
que les bonnes notse sont là , que les game ranked se passent bien peu importe le jeu auquel vous jouiez, que vous ne regardez pas trop
le décolleté des filles parce que vous avez suivis ce tuto !
je vous dit quoi , je vous dit à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo , portez vous bien, tcho tout le monnnnde.